mystery has been solved if there even
was a mystery it wasn't a photoshopped
image of jj watt he actually went old
school and wore a cardinals t-shirt when
it was time for him to let the world
know that he's the newest member of the
arizona formerly st louis formerly
chicago and along the way phoenix
cardinals good afternoon shireen how are
you
i'm good mike it's texas independence
day so we're showing our independence
again going 100 open so expect a t
stadium to be completely full this year
yeah completely full with no masks
either so independence absolutely yay
yay yay team all right uh so let's get
to it before i get myself in any more
trouble than i've already gotten myself
into today jj watt officially if you
haven't heard a member of the arizona
cardinals met with the media today
here's jj explaining why he chose the
cardinals and how much gas
is left in the tank
the longer i looked at the more it just
signs kept pointing back down here you
know there's there's a lot of exciting
things about what's happening down here
in arizona
i've always said in this league you have
to have a quarterback to have a chance
and there's a
young extremely talented quarterback
here who can do big things and it's
going from year two to year three and
can take an even bigger jump to continue
to grow and progress and be even better
um then you've got i mean you got
deandre hopkins who's one of the best
wide receivers in the league i'm
obviously very familiar with you've got
a defensive scheme and that's led by
vance joseph who i was with my first
three years down in houston uh when
under wade phillips and vance runs a
similar scheme to wade which is a scheme
i'm very familiar with and very
comfortable with and excited to play in
you've got guys like chandler jones and
buddha baker and guys all over that
defense that are really young excited
guys ready to get after ready to fly
around and make some plays so i'm just
very excited to be here and i'm also not
going to lie to you it doesn't hurt when
it's 65 degrees and sunny outside when i
woke up this morning so it's pretty nice
hey uh there's been so much talk uh
excitement in the valley about this but
also talk about how much gas you have
left at the tanks let us ask how much
gas do you feel like you have left in
the tank
a lot
a whole lot
this is his shortest answer since that
time he got all pissy with john mcclane
sorry london if you remember that
shereem i had forgotten about the vance
joseph connection you could once again
say vance joseph having the time of his
life now that j.j what is in town uh
i still don't know what to think of this
from a football standpoint because 32
years old injury history it's all
optimism now win the press conference
now sell the jerseys now we'll talk more
about the jerseys in a second
i still
want
to wait and see how it works from a
football standpoint
yeah no question mike and it already
looks weird to see him i know the texans
have some red in their jerseys but it
looks weird to see him in that cardinals
shirt jacket whatever it was it's
already weird and i know when he gets
that 99 on it's going to be even more
weird to see him in that but you know
you think back to the players that the
cardinals have signed in their history
that were kind of on the ends of their
careers you think to kurt warner it
certainly worked out for them they went
to a super bowl with kurt warner you
think about edran james worked out for
edran james they went to a super bowl
with edwin james emmett smith not so
much mike you know he i was there when
he showed up at the cardinals and and it
didn't work out for him there at the end
of his career
you know allen fanica went there for one
year i don't know if people get excited
for an offensive guard signing there but
you know i do know that the cardinals
fans were excited when kurt warner
edward james and emmitt smith
got there and and two of those signings
worked out and one of them didn't so i
think he's got something left it's
certainly seen he turns 32 this this
month it seems like he's older than that
and i guess it's all the injuries that
have piled up
i have no doubts that he will be a good
player for them if he can stay healthy
if chandler jones can stay healthy
opposite him he was double teamed 30.1
percent of the time according to espn
last season which was the most for any
edge rusher he hasn't been the same guy
since davion clowney left two years ago
his sac numbers have gone down over the
last two years four in 2019 and five
last season but if he has that guy on
the other side and chandler jones that
they have to double team and worry about
more than j.j watt i do think he can do
some things that he wasn't able to do in
houston last two years but the injuries
mike are a huge concern for me because
he's missed so many games over the last
few years they have to be a concern
stupid question that i could look up on
my own and hide my ignorance or i can
just ask you was emmett smith with the
cowboys of the cardinals when he broke
walter payton's record
he was with the cowboys actually played
the seahawks yep and he was with the
cowboys and then he went to the
cardinals after that
so so even more reason to say the time
with the cardinals really wasn't all
that memorable for emmett smith the one
thing that occurred to me earlier today
that i wish we had talked about last
night i've had three chances now to
finally think of this third time's a
charm
i think signing jj watt
is in a roundabout way an
acknowledgement that larry fitzgerald
will not be coming back because
what fills the gravitas void that larry
fitzgerald's absence creates if that
makes any sense at all different side of
the ball different position
but
what
steps into
what larry fitzgerald had become now be
great if they have both guys
but fitzgerald has never made a decision
or announced a decision this late in the
offseason that i can remember it just
makes me think they're bracing for him
to retire and part of the attraction for
watt is not just the fact that he gives
you a heart and soul of your defense he
he replaces that statesmanship that you
have with the larry fitzgerald if indeed
fitzgerald is calling it quits
yeah it makes perfect sense mike and i
hadn't thought about that but it does
make some sense on the other hand larry
fitzgerald has always wanted to win a
super bowl he's obviously played in one
and didn't get there didn't get over the
hump to win one so you'd like to see him
get that ring i know he'd like to get
that ring and maybe that's what he's
weighing right now how much do i come
back for the ring how much
will do i have to do what it takes over
the course of a season to prepare for a
season to to get into the season
cardinals are going to let him do what
he wants to do obviously and if he wants
to come back i'm sure they will welcome
him back with open arms but a lot
depends on what he wants to do if he
wants to go through that grind again
mike but you have jj watt now to kind of
fuel that role if larry fitzgerald
chooses to retire
you know this is about jj what not larry
fitzgerald and i didn't mean to get down
this path but
fitzgerald has never given off any vibe
that he'd play for any team other than
the arizona cardinals but man he has to
at least be pondering teaming up with
tom brady and getting in the slot
and becoming that security blanket for
tom brady that that would be
compelling if something like that would
happen and maybe you just wait and see
if chris godwin leaves then you turn to
larry fitzgerald but that's a topic for
another day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports